he's the voice of certainly Florida
certainly Miami and a friend of the show
and a great respect for him and we
wanted to start our Super Bowl coverage
with this and we wanted to start with
mr. Miami danlove Attard who joins us
now thought would be under different
circumstances did hey Dan kind enough to
join us he has his show that comes up a
ten-to-one
on the mothership so it's great to see
you putting on his headset true radio
guy
good to see you then yeah I wish
everyone was a little happier I see that
everybody this is not what I was
expecting to start Super Bowl week off
in Miami everyone's walking around a
little shell-shocked and you were with
the Miami Herald I think he started in
1990 and what 2016 is when you stop so
you we cover careers you know that we're
fortunate we've been there wire-to-wire
with people and if I said Kobe Bryant
the word that stood out to me was
curiosity because I saw him more as a
person not just a basketball player if I
said one word is there one competition
of holic yeah like that guy was a
cartoon manifestation of will rivaled
only by Michael Jordan in terms of
wanting there are plenty of people who
want but yeah he was curious that way
because of how he craved he craved
desperately can you remember anything
like this that we've covered sports why
not not in my lifetime like that
yesterday felt different than just about
any day I've seen in sports where I feel
like we all had a very similar reaction
it's disbelief it don't be true it's
checking to make sure it's true and then
you know the sudden arrival of grief and
then you see the mourning spread and it
had to be a little bit like you know
echoing beyond sports the way John
Lennon's death echo beyond music it had
to because you just you just had this
mass grieving and I think we had the
same kinds of thoughts right like beyond
just the horror of the tragedy what an
awful day for Vanessa Bryant his wife to
experience the loss of her husband and
the worst pain a human
feel the loss of a child and the
helplessness Kobe Bryant had to feel in
whatever were the last seconds of his
life not able to protect his daughter
from that it's it's just mortality from
someone we think of as kind of immortal
and I thought a Len Bias but Len Bias
was just starting his career and that
was self-inflicted but I remember being
in Brooklyn New York at a hardware store
and I heard the news that Len Bias had
died and I go Len Bias doesn't die
certainly not at that age yeah they're
supposed to be bigger stronger faster
bulletproof they're not as human as the
rest of us life isn't as frail for them
yeah
and that's that's why when I said
there's no way to start a show there's
no way to do a show like I think you
just kind of jump in and you go we go
where it takes us to go or where it
wants to go and even the guests that we
have on you I don't know if Jerry West
is gonna be capable doing an interview
today I saw him on TV and he looked like
he had just simply been crying down a
lot and then Reggie Miller he said look
we battled but I'm on the show on Monday
and he normally is on Tuesday and I said
we'll make way for you and you know I
just I think you get to this point like
how long do you grieve and then when do
you tell Stewart how do you celebrate
somebody like this because there is a
celebration to it that's why it hurts so
bad yeah but one of the reasons that
it's jarring is because of how at a very
top-end champion of champions the way
they go through retirement is we watch
them make that slow walk to the Hall of
Fame so we could celebrate and romance
all the memories all over again we're
supposed to get that that aging process
and we saw this guy we saw it physically
happen all of us watched him go from
young to old from a teenager to a legend
we watched that evolution we aged with
him you're supposed to get to cheat keep
cheering that as it goes you're not
supposed to have that taken away at 41
you know raising two young daughters and
then watching the golf yesterday and
Tiger gets the news as he leaves 18 and
he's going into the scorers tent and his
caddie Joe LaCava said hey I just want
to let you know cuz you're gonna meet
with the media Coby passed away
and he goes excuse me yeah that's it
with all of us it was all of us right
there was all of us like that can't be
right that can't be right
how does this affect you let's say your
show today we're just gonna stumble
around and fail and and you know try try
just try and as far as this coverage of
does your show would it have changed any
buy it the Super Bowl being here in
Miami I mean no we were deciding I'm you
know I'm a court jester we spoof sports
radio like it's supposed to be a party
it's supposed to be fun we are uniquely
ill-equipped to handle this particular
this particular mood yeah join the club
because I I just we went to dinner last
night and I didn't want to go got in the
car this morning and I said I I don't
want to do this I'm surprised those guys
played yesterday Mike Breen was saying
yeah I don't want a broadcast like
everybody I just I don't know what it
was like for Roberto Clemente to pass I
know that in my lifetime the the one the
the seismic one was Ali dying bigger
than all the rest but that just happened
so gradually it was not unexpected it's
not what yesterday was we're all over
sports and beyond everyone is reacting
the way Tiger Woods is which is what
what do you mean at least we had a
build-up to Muhammad Ali even Walter
Payton a little bit but when that
happens you know there there's still
that element of shock that goes along
with you can be it's like when your
parents both of my parents passed away
you know you know that it's gonna happen
but then there's still that day when you
walk in and then they're not there any
but he's supposed to be forever young
right he's a symbol for life like he's a
symbol for living the the the conquering
a bigger stronger faster and we saw all
of it with him like he you think about
what happened with him and that sexual
assault settlement and everything that
happened in Colorado and how the
marriage ended up staying together when
we thought the family was falling apart
right in front of us and for him in his
40s to have been at least on the outside
from afar what seemed like the portrait
of a family
man you see what happened and you how
could your heart not go out to the
families of everyone on that helicopter
how could your heart not go out to
Vanessa Bryan experiencing what she is
today
you stand leba tired of course his show
on ESPN
ten to one with Sue God's joining us
here Peter King will join us a little
bit later on Reggie Miller Jerry West
will stop by Michael Irvin will join us
I did reach out to you a couple of weeks
ago I don't know if you knew what I was
doing when I asked you when I said I
want to have our street artist RC give
us five portraits of Miami legends icons
when it came to sports and if you look
to your left that's one of them with
Michael Irvin and the you and that's
done by spray paint with our street
artist and Mike doesn't know that we did
it but we we have other ones each day
that we're going to unveil and that's
why I was saying give me five and then
you're goofing around saying you know
throwing in stugots is one of them five
and I go no no no I need five here right
and so you gave me a few more what did
you what did you end up selecting that's
something I'm sorry I thought you know
given the picture there alright we've
revealed one that's today all right yeah
and then it'll be another one tomorrow
and then one after that
I've days in the way and then Tyler Hiro
will be on Friday as one of those icons
if you're looking surveying here the
guys who look like they're dressed for
Miami
is there anybody Lord what is the matter
why no I wouldn't take them outside
anywhere here dressed like that
do you realize that these guys you know
they started working out because you
know okay
no no they started working out a week
ago to get ready for South Beach I said
it doesn't work that way guys so that's
what I'm stuck with here I mean I at
least threw a little you know color in
with my South Beach and you got any
Miami tips here for the for the guys I
mean you guys are gonna have some
difficulties moving around here shortly
this is a very small piece of land
they're dumping a whole lot of people on
it so I would I would choose the places
that you want to go now that are closer
to your hotel because you're not gonna
want to be going on and off this Beach
and then you got married and I got an
opportunity to go to your wedding and I
said I would go as long as I was the
biggest celebrity there yeah you upstage
the bride and then I realized I thought
I was in the clear I thought it was
doing pretty well I'm survey and you
know mean it comes in Sarah Spain and
you know there's some you know obviously
talented journalists there and I'll be
damned if Pat Riley doesn't walk in I'll
go damn it not the biggest name at the
leba tarde wedding were the best Silver
Fox do you think so well that's Riley
you still did you get my wedding gift oh
my god hold on a second Dan don't do
this to me don't do this to me I have
failed I have failed it says here's the
thing here's the true story we gave to a
bunch of we had people giving to
charities and we're a little disarmed a
little disorganized I asked you about
donating right but so we don't to the
zoo we don't know exactly who gave what
to wear and so we I'm ashamed to say we
have not sent out to thank you what did
you get my gift yes I got your gift but
you're gonna ask me to remember it now
and I'm gonna be ashamed Eric Valery
what a Dan Patrick there are there is
what did he get us okay you don't know
either oh my god wait I sent you a Dan
Patrick show calendar that was because
that's AG wedding gift
that that was because I'm a guest on
your show no piece of crystal a frame I
got two picture frame that's for that
that's the wedding picture if you wanted
to get a picture of me in there right a
picture let's do that you and me
together in that picture is fine I'll
wear Valerie's wedding dress okay Lenny
Rodman here okay but yeah I sent you an
autograph calendar thank you Dan I
appreciate I sent you a couple of shirts
and a couple of sent me a couple of
crappy hats yes coming from a guy who
wears crappy hats every day who's more
Authority I got you a crappy hat I would
have got any nice one and then you got
the the beautiful picture friend it was
a beautiful okay friend yeah but you
remembered no I did remember I'm sorry I
thought it was just for being a guest on
the show I thought look you run a
big-time outfit you're overlooking the
water here and despite my green room
experience that was between three ferns
everything is lavish and so I thought
you were just sending me for being a
guest on your show some crystal I didn't
know I did get it by the way two months
after the wedding well no there's a year
years period there I think but that's
you understand my confusion do you
understand when you set up no I was
honored to go I was honored to be there
thank you for being there what do you
think you'll be doing in 30 years from
now oh good god
I bought five years from now I'm just
creative stuff somewhere so I might want
to get you in trouble with the SPO just
creative just I'm going to be I probably
am NOT going to be working as hard as
the daily diarrhea we're producing today
as hard as your brothers that the show's
name daily Diaries would be stacked atop
a mountain of it yeah it but your
brother works really hard yes my brother
is very good libo art.com yes get your
plug in and if you retires what's to
gods do well he finds someone else he
drove you home and ever do good
Stu God's drove me home I'm William H
Macy's character in Boogie Nights where
I show up every day and on the driveway
he's flirting with someone else and and
I said a text to him the next day I go
hey I got home don't worry about me Stu
gods drove me home but why are my pants
on backwards and he goes what I said
yeah yes to God's drove me home in his
BMW and it was great at great time thank
you for stopping by
yes sir and I'm glad you enjoyed that
with that wedding gift that was really
special I'm gonna send them some clothes
all right I need some sizes here I need
some sizes I'm saying that I'm gonna
send them some I want to see see him
dressed a little bit differently
tomorrow No No thank you for coming by
thank you for having go entertain a
nation
he's dan-levitan to everybody for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]